my name's eep
star that's news and we're the world's
first family
the croods oh
another glorious morning dad always says
the pack
stays together that's my girl
seatbelt mode now we're searching for a
perfect place to call
what the home is that it's the end of
the world
well that's it for me i'm glad it's you
chunky
isn't it strange how this food grows in
perfectly strict
genius
[Music]
i thought cave people died off years ago
we
happy meet you
thanks oh we are the betterments
better man emphasis on the better
another teenage girl yeah a girl
friend i've never
i don't know if cave people belong in a
modern world
what's your problem big guy this place
is changing everyone
die and we really need to limit
thunk's window time not now douglas the
birds are on
in my day we didn't stare at birds we
fought them
let me live my life whoa what's that
it's just a scar
every mark is an adventure and my dad
doesn't even know about this one
whoa peanut toe
[Music]
you're not allowed outside the wall nope
this farm
is like your cave you're just like me
i feel like taking chance you see that
wall
yeah i want to jump in
we'll be back before anyone knows
you took dawn for a joy ride the
betterment built the wall
for a reason that's not good
the only way to survive is if the pack
stays together
in such a dangerous world i worry about
my family
too what's that
kill circle
today is a good day to die
hey everyone you'll never guess what i
found out sorry honey
we thought you were a predator trying to
kill us no never apologize for an
effective kill circle
hold on stop you accessorize with a
sloth i accessorize with the sloth
this is built mindset